in the oslo arena there magnus has
played in an arena like this before in
the tour finals both him anish geary and
young christoph duda
were gathered in this arena so young
christophe duda has as well experienced
this before with all the lights and all
the cameras will it be very different
for them david it's definitely different
uh i know when i was growing up playing
chess i was playing in kind of these uh
small school rooms in the back of
churches and
all over the place but there's never
lights like this never cameras in your
face and uh it's a different intensity
for the players it will take a while to
get used to doodle looks pretty chilled
i gotta say but uh either way uh for the
other players maybe the younger players
it's gonna be completely new and
yeah maybe this is the future definitely
and we do see they have headsets on
obviously to shut out any kind of sound
but they can also listen to music right
yeah and this is going to be exciting as
well because a lot of the players
especially the ones who didn't play in
the tour final in oslo yeah last year
they won't be used to this kind of novel
experience of putting their headphones
on and listening to their favorite tunes
yeah and then we see actually magnus
carson choosing his music right now wow
and i see that it's a list called
david's greatest hits challenge
for those of you who have been following
the tour last season i did try and slip
in some song titles to the commentary
and magnus is listening to some of those
songs oh that's cool